there are over 1 billion cars in the
world today getting people where they
need to go but cars aren't just a mode
of transportation they're also a
chemistry lesson waiting to be taught
the process of starting your car begins
in the engine cylinders where a spritz
of gasoline from the fuel injector and a
gulp of air from the intake valve mix
together before being ignited by a spark
forming gases that expand and push the
piston but combustion is an exothermic
reaction meaning it releases heat lots
of it and while much of this heat
escapes through the tailpipe the heat
that remains in the engine block needs
to be absorbed transport it and
dissipate it to protect the metal
components from deforming or even
melting this is where the cooling system
comes in a liquid gets circulated
throughout the engine but what kind of
liquid can absorb all that heat water
may seem like an obvious first choice
after all its specific heat the amount
of energy required to raise the
temperature of a given amount by one
degree Celsius is higher than that of
any other common substance and we have a
lot of heat energy to absorb but using
water could get us into deep trouble for
one thing it's freezing point is zero
degrees Celsius since water expands as
it freezes a cold winter night could
mean a cracked radiator and a damaged
engine block a chilling prospect and
considering how hot car engines can get
the relatively low boiling point of 100
degrees Celsius can lead to a situation
that would get anyone steamed so instead
of water we use a solution a homogeneous
mixture consisting of a solute and a
solvent some of the solutions properties
will differ depending on the proportion
of solute present these are called
colligative properties and as luck would
have it they include freezing point
depression and boiling point elevation
so solutions have both a lower freezing
point and a higher boiling point than
pure solvent and the more solute is
present the bigger the difference so why
do these properties change first of all
we need to understand that temperature
is a measure of the particles average
kinetic energy the colder the liquid the
less of this energy there is and the
slower the molecules move when a liquid
freezes
molecules slow down enough for their
attractive forces to act on each other
arranging themselves into a crystal
structure but the presence of solute
particles gets in the way of these
attractions requiring a solution to be
cooled down further before the
arrangement can occur as for the boiling
point when a liquid boils it produces
bubbles filled with its vapor but for a
bubble to form the vapor pressure must
become as strong as the atmosphere
constantly pushing down on the surface
of the liquid as the liquid is heated
the vapor pressure increases and when it
becomes equal to the atmospheric
pressure the bubbles form and boiling
occurs a solutions vapor pressure is
lower than that of pure solvent so it
must be heated to an even higher
temperature before it can match the
strength of the atmosphere as an added
bonus the pressure in the radiator is
kept above atmospheric pressure raising
the boiling point by another 25 degrees
Celsius the solution commonly used for a
car's cooling system is a 50:50 mixture
of ethylene glycol and water which
freezes at negative 37 degrees Celsius
and boils at 106 degrees Celsius at the
highest recommended proportion of 7230
the freezing point is even lower at
negative 55 degrees Celsius and the
boiling point rises to 113 degrees
Celsius as you can see the more ethylene
glycol you add the more protection you
get so why not go even higher well it
turns out you can have too much of a
good thing because at higher proportions
the freezing point actually starts to go
back up the properties of the solution
head towards the properties of ethylene
glycol which freezes at negative twelve
point nine degrees Celsius a higher
temperature than we attained with the
solution the solution flows through the
engine absorbing heat along the way when
it reaches the radiator it's cooled by a
fan as well as air rushing through the
front of the car before returning to the
hot engine compartment so an effective
and safe engine coolant must have a high
specific heat a low freezing point and a
high boiling point but instead of
searching all over the world for the
perfect liquid to solve our problem we
can create our own solution